el cesio-137 es un elemento radioactivo
usado para estudiar la erosión del suelo
y la sedimentación de las corrientes
tiene una vida media de aproximadamente
30 días ok eso es muy importante tiene
una vida media de 30 días es decir que
si nosotros empezáramos por ejemplo
con dos kilogramos de cesio con dos
kilogramos de cesio entonces después de
que transcurran 30 días 30 días vamos a
obtener la mitad solamente nos va a
quedar la mitad de cesio es decir un
kilogramo el otro kilogramo toda la otra
mitad se va a decaer en otras cosas
en fin supongamos que la cantidad
inicial a en becquerelios ok que falta
una n en becquerelios de cesio 137 en
una muestra de tierra está dada por la
función exponencial y tenemos aquí la
siguiente función exponencial para esto
déjeme agarrar este color esta es mi
función exponencial
donde t es el número de días que han
pasado después de la liberación del
cesio-137 en la tierra y se hiere son
constantes desconocidas ok
seguramente lo primero que te estás
preguntando es qué es esto de
becquerelios becquerelios bueno esta
cosa de los ve que ellos se refiere a
una cantidad pero no estamos
refiriéndonos a una cantidad de masa si
tú piensas en cuánto cesio hay bueno
podemos pensar en cuántos eso hay en
masa como aquí dos kilogramos y un
kilogramo pero también lo podemos pensar
como una cantidad de que tanto puede
producir radioactividad o qué tanta
actividad radioactiva tiene este exceso
137 y bueno él ve que ello es la unidad
internacional de radioactividad llamadas
y por henri becquerel quien descubrió la
radioactividad y ganó el premio nobel
por eso junto con marie curie el premio
nobel de física junto con marie curie y
creo que también estaba su esposo por
en fin a los pequeños lo puedes pensar
como cuánta actividad radioactiva tiene
siempre sencillamente lo podemos ver
como una cantidad y esta cantidad en la
que se miden este cesio-137 está dada
por esta ecuación que tengo aquí que es
más déjame apuntarle a justo aquí porque
es una ecuación muy importante dice am
aquí si te das cuenta es una función que
depende del tiempo entonces le voy a
poner aunque depende de la cantidad de
cesio que depende de ti está dada por c
que multiplica a r elevado a la t y
quiero que te des cuenta porque aquí es
muy importante que te está dado en días
en días y eso lo vamos a ocupar de hecho
por eso nos da la vida media te está
dado en días y tenemos una función
exponencial de lujo además supongamos
que sabemos que 50 días después de la
liberación de cesio-137 en la tierra
permanecen 10 becker ellos eso es muy
importante aquí sé que 50 días después
de esta liberación sea
mantienen permanecen 10 becquerelios en
nuestra muestra resuelve para las
constantes c y r ok
este dato que nos dan este dato que nos
dan nos dice que a a después de 50 días
es decir no estamos fijando en la
cantidad de cesio 137 que nos queda
después de 50 días bueno pues esto es lo
mismo que se por er elevado a las 50 ok
recuerda que esa cantidad de días y
bueno me dicen que quedan 10
becquerelios en esta muestra de la cual
no estamos fijando quedan 10
becquerelios ok ahora que nos preguntan
cuál es el valor de la constante r un
ser valor redondeado de r y bueno nos
dicen que este valor los redondeamos a
milésimas ok ahora como podemos obtener
el valor de r si te das cuenta aquí
tengo una ecuación solamente donde tengo
hace caer pero solamente tengo eso bueno
pues este es uno de los
típicos de funciones exponenciales este
tipo de problemas de radioactividad son
de los ejemplos más usados cuando uno se
ve este tipo de funciones exponenciales
porque son súper útiles y súper
importantes a mí me encantan y bueno una
forma de resolver todo este tipo de
problemas que tienen que ver con
sustancias relativas es la siguiente lo
importante de todo esto es fijarnos en
la vida media de ésta de este elemento
de esta sustancia y lo que quiero que
veas es que la vida media es de 30 días
así que vamos a suponer esto
imagínate que nosotros dejamos
escribirlas y empezamos con una cierta
cantidad de cesio-137 así que voy a
suponer que en el tiempo cero en el día
cero empezamos con una cierta cantidad y
le voy a llamar m m es la cantidad con
la que vamos a empezar ok pero bueno
esto si nosotros utilizamos la función
exponencial nos quedaría
r elevado a la 0 y bueno r elevado de
cero
esto es lo mismo que 1 y por lo tanto me
queda solamente 0 es decir que voy a
suponer que la cantidad con la que
iniciamos es lo mismo que se y de hecho
en todas este tipo de problemas eso
siempre pasa la cantidad con la que
empezamos es el valor de ese ahora
seguramente te estás preguntando para
qué nos sirve esto bueno porque ahora
voy a utilizar el dato importantísimo de
la vida media qué quiere decir eso y si
nosotros nos fijamos qué es lo que pasa
con la cantidad de cesio c-137 que queda
después de 30 días ok
bueno pues esto es exactamente lo mismo
que se lo voy a poner si que sé que
multiplica a r elevado a la 30 ok y esto
es exactamente lo mismo que la mitad de
la cantidad con la que empezamos
es decir que si nosotros empezamos con m
m era la cantidad de bécquer ellos que
tenemos en un principio después de 30
días ya qué pasó en nuestra vida media
nos van a quedar
entre 2 es decir justo la mitad ahora si
nosotros recordamos que se es igual a m
y eso es muy importante
fíjate bien en lo que estoy haciendo
como m es igual a c entonces voy a decir
que estoy utilizando esta parte de aquí
me quedaría que m por r elevado a la 30
ok esto es exactamente lo mismo que m
entre 2 lo que hice fue sustituir estas
en por esta m porque habíamos dicho que
m es igual a 0 que por cierto es la
cantidad inicial y ahora sí divido todo
entre m
si divido todo entre me voy a obtener
que r elevado a la 30 es igual a un
medio a un medio otra forma en la que tú
te puedes aprender este tipo de
problemas es que siempre pasa lo mismo
la razón o la base elevada la vida en
media en este tipo de problemas que
hablan de elementos radioactivos siempre
va a ser igual a un medio la razón
elevado a la vida media siempre es igual
a un medio y bueno esto siguiendo el
mismo procedimiento que acabamos de
utilizar
la cantidad de iniciales m y dándonos
cuenta que después de la vida media nos
van a quedar solamente entre 2 ahora
dividiendo todo entre m
voy a obtener que el elevado a la 30
estuvo a la un medio o como podemos
obtener el valor de r qué te parece si
elevó esta parte esta parte de aquí la
voy a llevar a la 1 sobre 30 ok y esta
parte de aquí también la voy a elevar a
la 1 sobre 30 y bueno dicho de otra
manera lo que ustedes si no sacar raíz
de la 30 de era la 30 o dicho de otra
manera de esta parte me queda solamente
r30 por uno de 30 es uno es decir
solamente me queda r mientras que de
esta otra parte me queda un medio
elevado elevado a la 1 entre 30 ok un
medio la vida media elevado a la 1 entre
la cantidad de días que tenemos de vida
media de lujo tú sabes cuánto es un
medio elevado a la 1 entre 30 bueno yo
tampoco sé así que voy a sacar mi
calculadora la tengo justo por aquí
a traerla y vamos a calcular a un medio
ok eso es punto 5.5
^ ^ lahm y voy a utilizar paréntesis
elevado a la 1 entre 30 1 entre 30
cerramos el paréntesis ok y esto va a
ser igual a 0.9 77 15 y todos demás
ahora nos dicen que usemos el valor
redondeado de erre en milésimas así que
aquí tengo las décimas centésimas
milésimas y al lado de la milésima que
es este 7 de aquí tengo un 1 por lo
tanto lo voy a redondear a 70.9 77
entonces lo voy a poner aquí ok ya tengo
el valor de r r es igual a 0.9 77 de
lujo esto redondeado en
a centésimas de luz entonces lo voy a
escribir aquí el valor de r 0.9 77 ok
pero date cuenta de la importancia de
esto ya tengo por fin la razón la razón
de esta función que yo tengo aquí de
esta función exponencial o dicho de otra
manera esta función que tengo aquí ya la
puedo escribir de la siguiente manera
para eso
déjame mover un poco todo esto dejando
el truco mover un poco para acá debe
mover un poco para acá ok
que me queda a bueno que esta función
esta función am a que depende del tiempo
ahora la puedo escribir como una
constante es en una constante c que
multiplica a la razón que ya sabemos que
es 0.97 7 ok
punto 97 7 elevado a la t elevado a la t
de lujo que me dice usted una pregunta
cuál es la cantidad inicial de
becquerelios en esta muestra de
cesio-137 redondea a centésimas y bueno
recuerda que la cantidad inicial y justo
lo habíamos concluido hace rato es ni
más ni menos que el valor de cm y el
ciclo saber es el valor de s para ella
tener todos los datos de esta ecuación
recuerda que m fue mi cantidad inicial
que por ciento habíamos dicho que es lo
mismo que sea yo te había comentado que
siempre era el famoso valor de s
así que qué te parece si ahora
utilizamos el dato que nos dan el dato
que nos dan es justo esto que tenemos
aquí recuerdas que a de 50 a de 50 es lo
mismo que hace por ere elevado a las 50
que esto es exactamente lo mismo que
1010 becker ellos el reloj que nos
quedan después de 50 días así que vamos
a ponerlo aquí a más de 50
no voy a poner aquí a de 50 es igual
hace que multiplica a r pero ya sabemos
el valor de r r es esta cantidad de aquí
de hecho te la voy a poner con ese mismo
color
eres 0.9 77 ok elevado esto a la
potencia 50 y esto esto me tiene que dar
igual a 10 esto me tiene que dar igual a
10 que es una cantidad de bécquer ellos
que nos dicen que nos quedan ahora vamos
a ver cuándo es 0.9 77 elevado a las 50
y para eso otra vez voy a sacar la
calculadora que la tengo justo por aquí
ok y ahora a esta respuesta antes que me
ponerlo así a esta respuesta la quiero
elevar la quiero elevar a la potencia 50
y esto va a ser igual a 0.3 1 498 todos
los demás ok entonces les voy a poner
como 0.3 cientos 14 315 déjenme
escribirlo aquí quiero que esto esto de
aquí me va a quedar que es ce que
multiplica se que multiplica a 0 punto
y esto es igual a 10 de lujo y ahora
como quieren saber el valor de s
voy a pasar esto del otro lado
dividiendo es decir que se es
exactamente lo mismo que 10 entre 0.3
115 ok y vamos a ver cuánto es esto
bueno pues voy a sacar otra vez la
calculadora la tengo justo aquí y yo
quiero saber cuánto es 10 entre a aquí
tengo entre punto 315 y esto es lo mismo
que 31.74 60 y yo lo quiero redondear a
centésimas por lo tanto decimos
centésimos ok
aquí al lado tengo un 6 por lo tanto
puede ser que suba 31.75 31.75 31 31.75
y ya está
empecé con una cantidad de 31.75
becquerelios cosas que no lo sabía antes
m mi cantidad inicial es 31.75 que que
de ellos que es por cierto
de esta constante entonces lo voy a
poner aquí 31.75 como se escribe que de
ellos ve que ellos ok b
d
los de lujo becquerelios ok pero además
ya estoy supercontento no solamente
porque tenemos la cantidad inicial sino
porque ahora puedo escribir
completamente esta función a de esta
función dt me va a quedar de la
siguiente manera
adt adt es igual a una constante sé que
ya la sabemos es 31.75 31.75 que a su
vez multiplican
ok cambiamos de color que a su vez
multiplica am 0.97 7 ok esto elevado a
la t esto elevado a la tema ya tengo por
fin esta función exponencial y por lo
tanto ya puedo saber para cualquier
cantidad de días cuánto me va a quedar
de becquerelios de hecho en la última
pregunta nos dicen lo siguiente cuantos
becquerelios de cesio 137 permanecieron
amanecieron después de 120 días de su
liberación en la tierra ha dicho otra
manera lo que yo quiero calcular es
cuánto a cuánto equivale y lo voy a
poner con este color a cuánto equivale a
de 120 días y bueno utilizando esta
fórmula es muy fácil calcularlo esto es
lo mismo que 31.75 esto que a su vez lo
multiplicamos por 0.97 7 elevado a las
120 ahora también hay otra forma de
encontrar justo esta misma respuesta
primero lo vamos a hacer de una manera
aproximada porque al final nos hemos
quedado con puros valores aproximados
pero aunque quiero que tú pienses justo
en la solución de este problema sin
utilizar la calculadora y bueno para eso
déjame traer otra vez la calculadora ok
y ahora quiero a ver pongámoslo con
calma quiero multiplicar 31.75 y ya esto
lo voy a multiplicar ok voy a poner
paréntesis x 0.97 7
1.97 7 elevado elevado a la potencia 120
ok y cierro paréntesis y esto tiene que
ser igual a wow solamente me queda 1.94
57 ok pues es hora de escribirlo 1 punto
lo quiero redondeado a centésimos 1.94 5
sube 1.95 lo voy a escribir aquí esto es
lo mismo que 1.1
punto 95 y lo voy a escribir aquí quedan
1.95 vétere ellos ok de lujo ahora
quiero que en este momento pausa es el
vídeo y te pongas a pensar por ti mismo
cómo podrías encontrar la solución de
este ningún problema pero ahora sin
utilizar la calculadora sobre todo esta
última pregunta que nos dicen que
queremos saber cuántos becquerelios
quedan después de 120 días
muy bien espero que lo hayas hecho
porque ahora voy a intentar resolverlo
yo sigue también algo que tiene que
lleguemos es a lo siguiente nosotros
redondeamos este 0.97 7 que salió de un
medio elevado a la potencia 1 entre 30
eso es lo que vale la razón de una
manera exacta ahora qué te parece si lo
utilizamos justo aquí es decir hace 120
lo voy a poner así adt a desde primero
es exactamente lo mismo que 31.75 ok que
multiplica a la razón pero la razón era
este número que tenemos aquí esto es lo
mismo que un medio y déjame ponerlo con
otro color y esto es lo mismo que lo voy
a poner con color blanco un medio
elevado esto a su vez elevado a la
potencia 1 entre 30 esto a su vez el
elevado de la potencia 1 entre 30 y todo
esto todo esto a su vez elevado a la
potencia de todo esto elevado a la
potencia temp o dicho de otra manera de
aquí podremos multiplicar las dos
potencias y me quedaría
y multiplicar voy a quitar este
paréntesis y entonces me voy a quedar
con un medio elevado elevado a la
potencia de entre 30 t entre 30 es decir
la potencia t que multiplica a un medio
elevado a la 1 entre 30 y bueno es que
esto me va a ayudar bastante para
obtener de una manera mucho más exacta
cuánto es de 120 ahora sí lo podemos
poner con este mismo color ok me
quedaría que a de 120 es exactamente lo
mismo que 31.75 31.75 ok y esto me queda
multiplicando y esto me queda
multiplicando a un medio a un medio
déjame ponerlo con este mismo color un
medio que a su vez está elevado que a su
vez está elevado al late entre 30 pero
te vale 120 por lo tanto me quedan 120
entre 30 lo cual es
esto es lo mismo que cuatro de lujo y
cuánto es un medio elevador de cuatro
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 31.75 ok
una elevada de cuatro es uno por 31.75
bueno pues es 31.75 entre dos elevado a
la 4 y 2 elevado a la 4 lo mismo que 248
1616 es decir yo quiero una dieciseisava
parte de 31.75 y bueno esto lo podemos
calcular de una manera muy sencilla o
inclusive lo podemos hacer también en la
calculadora ya es un cálculo mucho más
sencillo y no tenemos que sacar toda
esta ecuación que tengo aquí y cuánto es
31.75 entre esto entre 16 bueno pues
esto es lo mismo que 1.98 43 y aquí
tengo 1.94 57 hay una pequeña una ligera
diferencia entre estos dos valores así
que lo voy a poner aquí 1.98 43 1.98
aquí tengo 1.98 ok y entonces bueno de
una manera redondeada puedo tener 1.95
con un cierto margen de error todo eso
porque nosotros redondeamos este valor o
si nosotros no redondeamos este valor y
hacemos el cálculo de una manera
un poco más exacta me va a quedar 1.98
de lujo
todo esto trabajando con nuestras
funciones exponenciales así que espero
que te haya gustado este problema y
espero que te hayas divertido bastante
este problema es muy importante